Steve Kaufman here I'm gonna talk about
timing in language learning and as is
normally the case with these videos I
have a rough idea in my mind as to what
I'm gonna talk about and we'll see
what-what I end up what I end up saying
the rains have started here in Vancouver
after almost two glorious months of
sunny weather you know I often hear that
hear people say that there are different
learning styles
some people are oral or visual learners
and some people are kinetic learners and
I have never held felt that to be the
case and I've I think on my blog
the linguist on language I have made
reference to some work done by Professor
somewhere in the States who also doesn't
agree that we have different learning
styles I think essentially our brains
learn in the same way they've been
conditioned through evolution to learn
in a certain way and that is to to
basically form patterns to deal with the
experiences that the brain encounters
and so that also applies in my opinion
to language learning
however we are different in terms of
what we like to do and but even what we
like to do is gonna vary and I also
think that our ability to absorb
information to learn certain things
varies we're open to certain kinds of
information at certain times and not
open at other times we're going to
remember a certain structural pattern in
language or a certain word at some time
but that timing may not be when the
teacher is teaching it or when you're
trying to learn it it may be some time
later and there's also a question of
timing in terms of when we feel like
doing different things okay this sounds
a little bit confusing but let me try to
illustrate okay in language learning you
know there's there's a few I would say
there are three main activities
there is input/output some sometimes
they're combined if you're in a
conversation there's both input and
output and then there's going after the
nuts and bolts the details so we're
going after the nuts and bolts might
mean studying some grammar it might mean
reviewing your flashcards in my own case
at Linc I like to go into words that
I've saved and edit out the save phrase
tag them invest some time in these words
that I've saved even if I don't do it
for all of them if I do it for some of
them for example in the case of check to
try and get a handle on the cases you
know there's always this sort of
incidental learning factor if I do it
for a hundred nouns then I will start to
see it happening in another few hundred
dollars so I don't have to do it for all
hundred or a thousand or five thousand
dollars that I've that I'd say but the
question is timing when is it worth my
while to invest time in these nuts and
bolts whether it be grammar review
whether it be refining these words and
phrases that I've saved in link whether
it be vocabulary review when is the
right time to do it I happen to believe
that that one shouldn't do the same
thing every day that you know I gonna
spend yeah again if you have eight hours
a day to spend that doesn't matter but
if you have an hour or two to spend you
have to try to maximize the benefit of
your activity so if I'm tired I'm gonna
just listen or read it's easy to do I
might even throw on a video and even in
so far as going after the nuts and bolts
now in check I'm much more motivated to
do that now than I was at the beginning
at the beginning I had no words
it was just noise to me was just so many
words on a sheet of paper when I tried
to read it I have now accumulated enough
words that I can kind of pick my way
through a lot of these text
I'm ringing in from from the newspaper
but I'm a little confused as to the
cases and which prepositions take which
cases and these endings because in Czech
you know depending on their soft eye you
know the dictionary gives me all kinds
of stuff about soft vowels and or at
least soft I can't remember what it was
but they're soft and hard in there but
the main point is that there's no
regular pattern you know in terms of
which ending is identified with which
case I or you like II or whatever could
be the genitive singular genitive plural
dative singular plural it's all over the
map so yeah I've kind of looked over the
tables but now what I'm doing is I'm
going through the texts that I've
studied and either in the vocab section
or even on the lesson page I'm opening
up all these words that have the saved
phrase with them tidying up the phrase
and identifying and I've got open on my
computer a handy web page which has all
the check noun cases on them so I made
sure that I got it right a target right
and I do this and I feel that I'm really
getting a handle on it now that the
timing is right for me now to be doing
this activity you know if I were at some
course it would be the teacher who
decides when they're going to teach the
genitive like I you know or the data
ever or whatever and I might not I might
not be receptive to it so I think the
timing is so key in language learning in
terms of what activity we choose to do
in terms of what we want to do at a
given time either retired in terms of
what we're interested in also in terms
of of when our brain is most likely to
retain this information or to to to make
some use of it I mean the purpose of
studying the nuts and bolts whether it
be reading some grammar rule reviewing
some tables again as I was just saying
tagging some
words and phrases for their cases and
you know doing your Anki flashcards the
reason you do this is because in my
opinion it makes you more attentive when
you're listening and reading so that
you're when you're listening and reading
you're really able to to absorb to mine
those texts for all the structural
patterns that are there so that they can
become part of you so to summarize then
I think timing is very important timing
to match what you want to do timing to
match when a particular activity is
likely to me be the most effective and
very often that'll be when you feel like
doing it and so because I'm sure we have
all had the experience that you will
study a table of declensions or
conjugations and I mean all you're doing
is looking at it really it's not
penetrating its you can review it today
you can review it tomorrow the next day
nothing is happening because it's not
the right time the the soil is not
absorbing the nutrients you know that
you're trying to bring in it's the wrong
time whereas if it's the right time if
you want it you've noticed you've
struggled you want you want some answers
now for these you know language
phenomena that your brain has been
exposed to and is struggling to sort you
know to create some patterns for and now
these this review of the nuts and bolts
really helps you so I think I was asked
once where I spend my time and of course
I spent most of my time listening for
the main for the reason that it is so
easy to do I I in my car whatever I can
always listen I like to read as well so
reading and linking is a lot of my time
the nuts and bolts part of it is a much
smaller portion but I think it's very
very beneficial to go go at it when
you're in the mood when you have the
patience to do it to go at it in a
concentrated manner and if you really
want to do it then at that time you're
probably going to be more successful
doing it so there you have it that's you
know I I just wanted to say that I think
the time
timing of which of these output at least
activities input-output nuts-and-bolts
which one you do win is very important
and it's very important that the learner
be in charge of that process because if
the teacher is gonna force you to do
something that you don't want to do then
again you're not gonna get the benefit
and so while I am very much as you know
from my video is an input oriented
learner and I feel that input is key
that the input equals understanding your
understanding always has to be up here
your output ability is gonna be lower
than graslie increase but if you haven't
got this strong input base this strong
comprehension you're gonna struggle I
always struggle with your output but
there's also the nuts and bolts so
you've got to find the time which suits
you
to do these and and if you hit the
timing right your learning will become
much much more efficient so there you go
I look forward to your comments thank
you for listening